good afternoon i'm bill flynn
ceo of amtrak and joining me here today
are our amtrak chairman of the board mr
tony kocha
board director mr bert d clemente and
several other
members of our senior management team
and we welcome you here
to our 50th anniversary celebration
on may 1st 1971 the first amtrak train
rolled out of new york city
on route to philadelphia where we're
gathered here today
and certainly at that time no one could
have imagined
what would lay ahead and today we're
here
representing our more than eighteen
thousand dedicated employees
they operate a national system serving
over more than 500 destinations
across 46 states the district of
columbia
and three canadian provinces and we have
tens of millions of loyal amtrak
customers
and i'm honored to be joined here today
by perhaps
one of amtrak's most loyal customers the
46th president of the united states
joe biden mr president
i thank you for being here to mark this
milestone with us
and for your tremendous support of
amtrak
throughout your career of serving our
nation
the american jobs plan which includes 80
billion dollars for rail
is just what the country needs as we
build for the future
america needs a rail network that offers
frequent
reliable sustainable and equitable train
service
amtrak has the vision and the expertise
to deliver it
now we need congress to provide the
funding for the next 50 years
our vision includes expanding rail
service to connect
to up to 160 new communities throughout
the united states
and by building new and improved
corridors
in over 25 states as part of this
comprehensive plan
amtrak will introduce new stations in
over half of the united states
increase rail service to 47 of our top
50
metropolitan areas and create over half
a million new jobs
new well-paying jobs but we're not
stopping there we're investing in our
fleet
last week we announced the procurement
of 83
inter-city train sets which will operate
on the northeast corridor
and various state-supported and
long-distance routes
and we will soon debut the new
high-speed acela train sets
setting the stage for the next
generation of train travel
in america and on our northeast corridor
we're investing in our stations in
january our partnership with the state
of new york we with our partnership with
the state of new york
we opened moynihan train hall amtrak's
new home in new york city
a world-class station providing an
enhanced customer experience
and we are advancing station
modernization projects
in other major cities chicago washington
dc
baltimore and right here in philadelphia
we're investing in our infrastructure we
are making important strides on vital
infrastructure projects
up and down the northeast corridor
projects such as our gateway program
and the rebuilding and replacement of
the baltimore potomac tunnel
planned infrastructure projects will
increase track capacity
improve wide quality and offer greater
reliability
all of these projects are investments in
our future but they're also
investments in our planet amtrak
provides a more sustainable mode of
travel
and demand for rail travel will continue
to grow
in fact traveling on amtrak emits up to
83 percent
fewer greenhouse gas emissions than by
driving
and up to 73 percent fewer ghgs
than by flying we have a truly dedicated
workforce in amtrak that carries on the
legacy
of the railroaders who served before
them and who take great pride
in connecting america and it's because
of our employees
that amtrak serves a vital role in our
country's mobility strategy
we continue to see their important
contributions play out in real time
as we navigate through the kovid 19
pandemic
when the world stopped in many ways due
to the spread of the coronavirus
our employees really indeed all
transportation employees
made sure america kept moving
they were on the front lines every day
providing the essential transportation
services
to those who needed it and now more than
ever
amtrak is ready to provide the safe
journey that travelers are seeking
as our nation recovers from the effects
of this pandemic
it's been an honor to lead amtrak during
this critical time
i come from a railroad family like so
many other fellow
amtrak colleagues do my father and uncle
were both locomotive engineers
my brother david was an amtrak conductor
and local union chair
with over 40 years of service my brother
brian works at amtrak now with
over 15 years of service to the company
these connections deepen my pride in
amtrak
and my commitment to further amtrak's
important mission to serve our country
we have much to celebrate today and more
to look forward to in the future
in closing i'd like to thank those who
paved the way
we owe you a tremendous diet of
gratitude i salute the men and women who
make up amtrak workforce
our partners political leaders on both
sides of the aisle
and our many stakeholders whose tireless
efforts
keep our railroad running and of course
to our customers thank you for your
continued support
get ready america while amtrak may be
turning 50
we're just getting started and now it's
my pleasure to welcome to the podium mr
blake weaver who's an amtrak conductor
here in philadelphia who will introduce
the president
thank you blake
thank you mr flynn i too am part of a
railroad
sorry i too am part of a railroad family
my father was a conductor for over 40
years and i've been one for the last 18.
i joined amtrak on president's day in
2004 as assistant conductor
and after a couple years i was promoted
to a conductor i can honestly say i love
what i do
i like having the opportunity of working
with my co-workers to serve amtrak's
customers up and down the northeast
corridor
to get them safely and on time to where
they go
i'm proud of amtrak's mission and
especially proud
of how hard they work during this
pandemic and keeping essential
passengers across
america moving i'm also excited to see
the rest of our passengers back on our
trains
very excited to see him on our brand new
cells cell express sets
one of my first lessons my father taught
me as a conductor was to look out for
one of amtrak's most frequent writers
senator joe biden
in 2006 i had the private i had the
privilege of meeting mr biden
on the train while collecting tickets
before i had a chance to introduce
myself mr biden stopped what he was
working on
invited me to sit down and talk to him
for a few minutes
i always remembered how he treated
everyone
he always made time for both the
passengers and the employees
he also treated everyone like they were
family
so mr president i'd like to thank you
for all the support you have given
amtrak
like you thank for all the miles you
added up over the years
i'd like to thank you for being part of
the amtrak family i would like
thank you for being part of my family
ladies and gentlemen
i'm proud to introduce the president of
the united states of america
mr joe biden
hello everyone great to be back in play
great to be back to 33 33 station
blake you didn't uh
you didn't treat each other like family
or family please sit down guys sit down
your dad greg is here too as far as i'm
concerned the weavers are family
and justin gray speaking of family your
father and i fought a lot of fights
together
planned a lot of those fights on amtrak
coming back to philly
i didn't come all the way to philly it's
wonderful tribute to the
to this station to bear's name and uh
bill flynn thank you for having me
governor wolf mayor kenny
congressman evans thank you for the
passport into the city appreciate it
and we have another i don't know they're
all here still but i met a lot of really
important friends
that were here to uh for this edition i
understand
senator blumenthal is here there you go
one of the great senators
former attorney general took care of my
son bo
when he was attorney general thank you
very much and also
dwight evans dwight's here you can't
miss dwight come on dry stand up there
man
and uh a good friend of mine and worked
like the devil to get me elected brendan
boyle brendan
that's the irish of it man and donald
payne
new jersey i keep telling donald
because delaware's so small it is a
constitutional
there was a case in the supreme court
delaware the state of owns the delaware
river up to the high water mark in new
jersey just want you to know that
you got to treat us with more respect
and uh
mayor kenny thanks for the passport
great friend thank you mr mayor you're
doing a heck of a job
and uh a real close close friend who was
a co-chairman of my campaign and
just a great friend is our whole time
governor ed rendell eddie thank you pal
this city owes you a lot and tony costa
chair of the chairman of the board and
one of my best friends in
in life guy named bertie clementine
we've known each other from high school
we went to rival high schools bert ran
my operation in delaware
for years and years the one election i
got the most votes in was the last
election i ran for the senate i was also
running for vice president at the time
because under delaware law if you're not
out of the senate race in a certain
time period you got to stay in and so
bert
ran he was the senator in delaware
campaigning for me
he got more votes than i got so bert
thank you very much
also justin gray i've mentioned justin
already and his dad
uh and greg weaver junior
uh greg you're you are family uh i mean
excuse me blake
and his family and mary kate what a
lovely kid and bill flynn
of amtrak you know folks uh the fact
is that uh if i have
in the past when i've ended up at the
30th street station amtrak station
it's probably because i took the late
train back from washington
and i slept through the delaware stop
literally not figured only did it about
four times
but uh but i would have uh i wouldn't
have missed this for the world
it's an honor to celebrate amtrak's 50th
anniversary
i look forward to a bright future for
all american rail
you know back in 2016 uh
i announced a federal loan that allowed
amtrak to purchase
the new acela trains as sets as you see
behind me
and they look great i can hardly wait to
ride and they made and they're made in
america and i wanted to see more of that
that's why the investments in my
american jobs plan are guided by one
principle
by american byproducts were made in
america
and american tax dollars are going to be
used to buy american products to create
american jobs when i became vice
president
one of uh the capitol hill newspapers
estimated
that i had taken more than 7 000 round
trips in amtrak over my career
i think that's an exaggeration and i'm
gonna rely on those two conductors
and that mr weaver remember
uh one of them was a guy named angelo
negri
and angelo there was an article my i
guess my
fourth or fifth year as president vice
president
saying biden travels one thousand one
million three hundred thousand miles on
air force one
and i used to the secret service didn't
like it but i used to like to take the
train home my mom was
sick and i'd come try to come home
almost every weekend as vice president
to see her and i was getting on the
train
and angelo negri came up and he goes
joey baby
and he grabbed my cheek started to
squeeze it like he always did
and i thought he was going to get shot
i'm serious and i said no no he's a
friend he said joey
what's the big deal a million two
hundred thousand three hundred thousand
miles
on air force two you know how many miles
you travel on amtrak
i said no ange i don't know he gave me
the calculation
and he said you hundred travel 1515
thousand miles on amtrak so the fact is
i probably take anger's word before i
took the word of
what the article said but the point is
in the process
as uh conducting rave will tell you
amtrak
became my family i literally literally
every single day that i was in the
united states senate
got the the the 7 28 it became the 732
and or and got home on if i got lucky i
got to
i got the metro that left the last one
left at six i got to 7
30 coming home and you get to know
everybody
you get to know the folks and i used to
have a a christmas party
for amtrak employees at my home that got
so big we ended up having a summer party
because family and retirees kept coming
back
i want to tell you these guys and women
they work like the devil
they really really really do and amtrak
wasn't just a way of getting home
it provided me and i'm not joking an
entire other family
a community dedicated that was a
professional
and that we've shared milestones in my
life
and i've been allowed to share
milestones and dares
i've been an awful lot of weddings and
christenings and
unfortunately some burials as well we're
family
you know i uh i remember one night my
daughter was only
six years old and it was my birthday
and uh we were voting i went to bob dole
and i said bob
when's the next vote going to take place
said joe what why i said well
my daughter is really upset i'm not
gonna be able to be home for the
birthday cake she made for me
he said what do you need i said i need
just time to catch the five o'clock
metro
and i can get the 628 coming back
because in the
platform yes in delaware you walk from
one side to the other
got off the train my wife jill stand
there
my daughter had the cake with the candle
lit
i blew them out gave me a kiss walked
across and got on the southbound
so it has been part of my life i've been
riding in amtrak for almost as long as
there's been an amtrak
i've come to see that amtrak doesn't
just carry us from one place to know
that it opens up enormous possibilities
and especially now it makes it possible
to build an economy of the future and
one that we need
last week i announced the target of
cutting greenhouse gases
and gas emissions in half by 2030.
and most of that of those emissions in
this in this account in this country
come from transportation but if just 10
of the freight ship and the largest
trucks went by
rail instead we'd be removing 3 million
300
000 cars from the road and we've been
planning is the same as doing that or
planting
260 million trees in america as i've
said from the beginning when i think
about
fighting climate change i think about
jobs and rail
and hopefully the expansion of rail
provides good
union jobs good paying jobs it also
connects people to jobs
and economic opportunities that can be
reached
from wherever you live let's put this in
perspective
for years i fought efforts to cut
funding for amtrak
because cutting funding for amtrak would
be a disaster for our environment
and our economy amtrak carries
four times as many riders between
washington and new york city
as every single airline does
within 50 miles of the shore
from florida all the way up the coast
imagine what we'd have to do a single
day without the northeast corridor for
example
with amtrak and the northeast corridor
would cost the economy
100 million dollars if you shut down all
passengers
passenger service on amtrak's northeast
carter the projects
that compensate for the loss you'd have
to add
seven new lanes of highway on i-95
and consider that cost average of 30
million dollars for a linear mile on
i-95
this is the bargain of bargains and
bargains it's economical
and it's environmentally a lifesaver
that's why in my rescue plan american
rescue plan
we worked hard to keep amtrak running at
the heights of the pandemic because we
weren't
traveling amtrak furloughed one million
1
200 employees and we were able to
provide emergency relief to keep rail
service running
and we've now brought back 1200 union
workers
who had been furloughed and by the way
you get a union wage not 15 bucks an
hour
a prevailing wage but we have to do more
than just build back
we have to build back better and today
we have a once in a generation
opportunity position amtrak
and rail and inner city rail as well in
general to play a central role
in our transformation and transportation
economic future
to make investments that can help
america get back on track no pun
intended
before the pandemic kid amtrak's
ridership and revenues were on the
upswing
the northeast carter has been making
money for a long while now but last year
the whole of amtrak system was projected
to break even
for the first time in history but then
we had the pandemic
but there is still a huge backlog and
deferred maintenance
huge need to modernize our trains our
stations our bridges
our tunnels well we're taking we're
talking about
critical jobs like the hudson river
tunnel the baltimore
potomac tunnels and the susquehanna
river bridge
in my american jobs plan i propose
spending 10 billion
a year on passenger rail and freight
rail
of this two-thirds which support
existing ranch
tr amtrak routes including the northeast
corridor but nationwide
and we're talking about union jobs as i
said
and we tried we're taking care of the
riders laying track wiring switches
fixing bridges tunnels modernizing
stations
and repairing and rebuilding this vital
infrastructure
this would allow for the potential to
expand
passenger rail service imagine
a two-hour train ride between atlanta
and charlotte
going to speeds of 220 miles an hour
and two and a half hour trip between
chicago and detroit
or faster and more regular trips between
los angeles las vegas
a route that i imagine could be pretty
popular on fridays
bill as you've said your vision for
amtrak calls for a new inner city rail
service
up to 160 previously unserved
communities
being connected think of what it will
mean for opportunity if we can connect
milwaukee to green bay to madison
scranton and allentown to new york
indianapolis to louisville
and much much more it's going to provide
jobs
will also accommodate jobs and what this
means is that towns and cities that have
been
in danger of being left out and left
behind will be back in the game it means
families
don't have to sacrifice the cost of
living or quality of access
to opportunity that sometimes only
occurs if they live in a big city
we have a huge opportunity here to
provide fast safe reliable clean
transportation
in this country and transit is part of
the infrastructure
and like the rest of our infrastructure
we're way behind the rest of the world
right now
we need to remember we're in competition
with the rest of the world
people come here and set up businesses
people stay here
people grow because of the ability to
access
access transportation access all the
infrastructure
it's what allows us to compete and with
the rest of the world
to win the 21st century we've got to
move china already has
23 000 miles of high-speed rail
220 miles per hour
two-thirds of all the high-speed rail in
in in the world
220 miles an hour and the way
and they're working on uh transit on
trains
that can go as high as 400 miles an hour
we're behind the curve but folks as i
said the other night
america is on the move again we need to
remember that we're in the united states
of america
there's nothing beyond our capacity
nothing we can't do if we do it together
and we celebrate amtrak's birthday i was
thinking about america
amtrak's role as i said on my birthday
when they allowed me to come home and
blow out that candle
there's a lot of things that amtrak does
and you know the
fact of the matter is if we were able to
which is now beyond the ability to pay
for it
but if we're able to straighten out
three curves from washington
to new york you could make it from
washington new york in an hour and 32
minutes
an hour and 32 minutes folks there's so
much we can do
and it has such a incredibly positive
impact on the environment
incredibly positive impact on work
president
on on opportunities and again
all the things we have to do to put
amtrak in place
and be one of the great great
contributors to our country
is we have to invest and so
you know uh if you think about it
when we were when i was vice president
with barack he allowed me to put
together
a budget for amtrak and it had money for
high-speed rail
at 200 miles an hour from
from uh uh char assuming from charlotte
one and another line going from
in florida down to tampa another line if
we had moved go we'd have that tunnel
fixed in new york now
the money was there to get it done
there's so much
we can do and it's the biggest bang for
the buck we can expend
so on this momentous birthday of amtrak
i want to
i want to thank you for making so many
birthdays possible
i believe that the best days ram track
for rail and for america are ahead i
really believe that
and i'm just confident i'm confident we
can get this done
and i must tell you i'm anxious to see
the new train thank you all
so very much god bless america and may
god protects our troops
thank you thank you thank you
energy
okay
you